it's the biggest change in British arms
policing in a generation we've been
given unprecedented access to the new
recruits I'm a quiet or I'll split the
ones who could be first in facing the
terrorists they are armed and carrying
big responsibility the marauding gunmen
that struck in Mumbai back in 2008
changed the thinking of UK police forces
first Paris attacks saw roaming gunmen
in the heart of Europe but it was the
simultaneous strikes in November that
changed everything
scene after scene of mass murder we now
live in a constant state of alert across
Europe we've seen cities in lockdown and
more weapons on the streets to both
deter and protect in the UK the response
in part is this the biggest surge in
armed officers that UK police forces
have ever known and when I looked at
that I just kind of talked I hope I
never have to deal with that but I also
talked so anyway I better prepare in
case I'd ever happens and that's what
we've been doing literally from the
Mulley afterwards we started planning
and preparing there seems to be getting
closer and closer and it used to be all
what if I think now people are when we
know there is a determination to
attacking the West from DICE and
actually the decision after Paris really
was that that was a game-changing moment
and it was right to take a sort of more
assertive posture about how we
positioned firearms in placing keep
those fingers up the trigger when the
call went out after Paris these are the
men and women who put up their hands
experienced unarmed officers want to
join the West Midlands police firearms
unit course is grueling and takes months
to get through take your time Alicia is
normally a Detective Sergeant this is
day one with the carbine gun a compact
semi-automatic rifle
he's not easy initiative all right well
I'm going I'm left-handed usually yeah
and I submit to try shoot right-handed
as well so website the mechanics are a
little bit alien to me so I'm just
trying to get used to that as well you
know you do have press coverage as soon
as an officer shoot somebody everybody
starts to look for a reason to point the
finger at the officer and find fault
with the decision and that for me that
was more of a thought you know something
to really sit down and think about could
I deal with that the number of shots
actually fired from real by all armed
officers in a whole year is usually in
single figures each one though
loaded with implications and you ask
them out right you make it clear it many
many stages long way what they're taking
off absolutely and on day one of assault
because all that's yes the question
could you take somebody's life could you
deal with it emotionally could your
family deal with emotionally and
obviously that is constantly in the
forefront of their minds as they
progress through the training the number
of armed police had actually been
falling now to meet the perceived threat
1,500 extra officers are retraining
across England and Wales andy is also
one of them 20 years in the force and
ready for something different his
accuracy improving all the time
you seem more confident with it now I'm
more confident with the weapon again and
that's just because girls have done
again and again again so it's it is it
is practice every time you stand there
it's still a daunting experience like
every student here a debt has thought
long and hard about what she's taking on
I have no knowledge of guns before I
came
yeah so I find that the working parts
with it when they explain what they're
doing what they just and why it all
makes sense and then you you're shooting
just gets better when you actually feel
you've got control you can shoot then
the reality kicks in a little bit more
the training is really really difficult
and it should be if for any second for
me for any second I didn't feel it was
the right path for me I'd also pull out
of the process what yeah extra pressure
the potential consequences it's not
actually anything extra in their pay
tacit oxygen training here or indeed
their colleagues who are already
qualified out on the streets of the West
Midlands they are here as volunteers if
they make it through every stage of the
course they could be picking up their
weapons for real at the police Armory
here each officer is assigned their own
weapons it's down to them to confirm
that they and their firearms are ready
for a shift
armed police patrols are often first in
officers like Rob and Alex
I just have a quick word make sure we
get the stops I'm developing so it can
be anything from a drunken argument like
that one thank you
like right through to international
terrorism
I don't want an attack to happen by any
stretch of the imagination
but I don't think I don't think I'll
have the right moral character to be a
police officer it for the first sign of
danger I turned away and you know handed
in a badge or said I'm not doing this
you know I'll go and work in an office
or some friends family no be aware of
what's happening in the world you know
they are concerned but having a really
really quickly old training Lee I know
we're no hero a better position than
most to deal with that you know that
that threat shape even when it does
arise but completely different ball
grain I think in a terrorist type attack
- perhaps a regular firearms incident
and the threat level is obviously going
to be much much higher I think the
people that potentially would be going
up against their mindset is totally
different to that of an armed robbery I
would suggest that I want you think
Albert you know they're playing a very
very different games for different set
of rules
because of that the orders have changed
this exercise in London last year showed
what it might look like here it's
drilled into them even for qualified
firearms officers the training is
refreshed again and again there are many
different scenarios that they train for
of which a marauding terrorist firearms
incident is just one and for that reason
we can't show you if you think that they
are doing we can't film absolutely every
tactic that is quite understandable but
the reality is that most of these
officers will be dealing far more with
instance perhaps of domestic violence
for example I complain the electronic
all their job is to tackle all kinds of
violent offenders so if they did come
face to face with a gunman firing
indiscriminately their instruction is to
shoot that individual as an absolute
priority you have to make the decision
that is gonna be the one that saves the
lives and you know it might mean that
momentarily your you are leaving people
injured possibly dying people calling
for help I don't step over and if I
don't walk past than if I don't continue
then I am a greater target as are more
as my colleagues and more of the public
I would be armed and be able to take
that dumpty take that purse and take the
shot if need be and and stop them so
gently the sharp end of Lisa makes you
realize just how serious things okay
Steven crag is a top human rights
barrister who's worked on many cases
where police forces have got it wrong
that's sending clients who suffer from
an accessibility
please rating right health is it's very
hard to discern any way in which the
police have decided they need twice as
many armed police officers at the moment
one of the problems is that there's no
national record kept by the police on
use of force and so there's nothing for
them to base the increase on the
temptation must be for police to use
firearms off officers or more occasions
and there's a risk that they'll be used
in situations where they're not now and
probably don't need to be the face of
that the home office is funding this
increase in numbers and equipment it's
happening in urban police forces across
the UK we've doubled doubled our
response farms response at key times and
key locations and we're working towards
to having that 24/7 all over the West
minute so yeah if we had something
happen and I hope it doesn't I think
when I reach really strong position to
deal with it quickly and effectively if
I was a new street station or the
bullring shopping center how close your
offices they'll be done be a vehicle
with a quarter mile there would be a
vehicle within a couple of minutes of
respond so I can commonly say that
because we move our vehicles around we
change on intelligence every day where
we deploy them but as effectively as
possible to the threat to time but our
key places where there is crowded places
a lot of people around you're talking
minutes at any time 24/7 West Midlands
Police haven't had any fatal shootings
in the past 20 years but across England
and Wales since 2004 24 people have been
shot dead by police officers
I am really committed the British
policing has to and should remained an
alarm service it's vitally important
because it's the style of policing we've
got terrorism shouldn't change that it's
vital we build good links with the
community and being armed would I think
interfere with our and it enables me
actually to pick only the absolute best
officers to be training the use of
firearms some students won't make the
cut but for most the people in their
sights will soon be real almost always
they will defuse situations through
simply talking but being ready for the
worst-case scenarios is now more
relevant than ever the threat is there
on every shift